哈喽大家好 欢迎来到今天的文化有限 我是超哥 我是大一 我是星光。
大家好 这礼拜我们跟大家聊的这本书啊 好像应该是我们文化有限自建台以来还没有聊过的一类书 是不是咱们没聊过这种书。
就是这个名人自传 其实我还真就这个事 查了一下咱们之前的节目啊？
咱其实名人传记作品咱真聊过 特别特别早的时候。
84期教主来串台的时候 咱们聊的是天生有罪 吹完了那个 吹完了变色人生 就那一本。
真的就是纯的严格的个人传记 就那一本 对 而且还是教主给咱们提名了 咱们四个人好像从来没想过。
对 然后所以我们今天跟大家聊一本书啊 这个传记就是来自于好莱坞著名的影星。
也是奥斯卡影帝了 马修麦康纳的绿灯。
大家可以在留言区跟我们说说 如果你读过这本书 可以跟我们说说你的阅读感受。
如果你特别喜欢马修麦康纳 欢迎给我们推荐一些你觉得它特别好的作品。
可以跟我们分享分享 不让你的人生当中 有没有遇到一些黄灯和红灯时刻。
你是怎么通过的 怎么让它变成绿灯的 也跟我们分享。
我们会从评论区选出五位听友送出这本马修麦康纳的绿灯 这只是书这一本。
这本书是我给它俩提名了 我提名了。
说说吧 为什么选这本书呢？
特神奇是过年的时候 先生有一朋友来我们家喝酒。
他说他最近看这书特别受启发。
他是喝完说的还是喝之前跟你说的。
边喝边说 然后我就打开了豆瓣 一打开之后我就被劝退了。
因为前三个都是差评 有人说是什么？
说这就是好莱坞的大兵 说马修麦康纳这本书。
好来我打兵 还有说 这全是流水帐。
还有人说这完全是一个就是和耳蒙爆棚的老男人自说自话 自己吹牛。
我一看完就和上了 而且就是都是打一行 我就和上了没看。
然后有一天 应该是过年期间 我打开了朋友圈那天 特神了。
就是往下翻了两瓶 同时有三个人在发这本书。
而且这三个人是分别在不同的国家 从事不同的职业 也是不同的性别。
第一个人是我师弟 我师弟现在是在美国NBA的发展联盟当助理教练。
然后也是我们国家南兰的助理教练 就是一个体育生。
然后就是他不是那种经常会发书的repo的人。
然后我觉得他要发什么这个乔丹传啊 什么柯比传啊 我理解。
然后他发了马修麦康那个传 他说这是他开年的第一本读完的书 特别感动。
他也用了书里的话 应该就是这本书的最后一段话 就是你的人生 你做的所有决定。
就是你的life is your resume 对吧 你的人生是你的简历。
然后你做的那些选择构成了你人生故事的各种章节什么的。
然后我就说 哇 他为什么看这个书 然后接着再往下翻是一个我当老师的朋友。
然后他说他的同学就是给假期不是留这个留读书笔记。
有一学生应该在读这本书给他推荐的。
然后他结了一个学生给他的那个聊天纪录上面写了一句话 特别触动我。
他说人生如果没有红灯和黄灯 绿灯毫无法给人带来喜悦。
就大概是这个话 我说 哇 这可以 就是一个高中生。
他看完这本书让他感受到了勇气 很有折扶。
对 然后我就说那不行 我得看看这本书 我就当时就下单了这本书。
就翻开来看 然后这本书打动吸引我的一开始。
一个是马修麦康娜 我还挺喜欢她演的戏 但是我对这个人完全不了解。
我开始看马修麦康娜的电影 就是从达拉斯买家俱乐部。
后来就是经济穿越 然后后来还看了一季侦探。
已经是她转型后的硬看的形象 但是这个人在我心中。
我就知道她是一个演技特别好的人 她是谁 我完全不知道。
稍微有点好奇 然后这本书后边对于她的介绍特别吸引我。
我就是先翻开的时候 看她的介绍 我给大家念一段。
这个介绍是这样的 说 马修麦康娜是两次离婚。
三次结婚的姬母和凯蒂麦康娜之子。
就先说 你看她这个家庭 她爸和她妈。
两次离婚三次结婚都是和彼此 你就觉得她爸她妈。
应该有点意思 然后她说 已婚已育有三个孩子。
她自称受到上天眷顾 并将自己定为一个讲故事的人。
她写诗 还是一位时运不计的音乐家 扩耗。
但是还有时间 还有希望 她是自驾中绝佳的伙伴。
认为在去寺院庙语的路上 小卓一杯啤酒。
不是什么大问题 一天下来汉流甲辈的她状态甚佳。
马修是一个认真生活的男人 在这个世界上如雨得水。
她喜欢先找相同点 再挑点不同点 并且永远在生活中求同存异。
她会款款低引浅畅 在吹口哨上天赋异禀。
她是一位摔脚手 一位自立门户的词源学学家。
也是一位周游世界的旅游家。
她坚信 伤疤才是最有个性的闻生。
在知命之年 自然生长出的头发 要比35岁时还要多。
她在全球展霍过六次银水比赛的冠军。
为了让食物更加美味 而会在饭前祈祷。
她特别会起外号 研究美食和建筑 热爱知识汉堡和食罗泡菜。
一直在学习说对不起 就是这个介绍也很吸引我。
这和我自己刻板印象里一个金光闪闪的腰眼的影帝的介绍。
完全是不一样的
你看没有任何一句关心她在电影和表演上取得的成就。
然后这个人还又是词源学家 还写诗 还不成功。
对吧 然后还是时运不计的歌手。
我就觉得她的人生应该挺有意思。
所以就是种种原因促使我翻开了这本书。
然后翻开完这本书之后呢 我就推荐给了他们两位。
可能大老师看过程中有点卡对。
确实也是觉得有点像流水帐 坦白说。
然后也给大家提醒 如果你是一位特别喜欢电影的人。
希望从这本自传里边能看到她对于电影 表演的这些思考和礼物。
那没有 那你可能要失望了 不劝你去看。
我就是这种失望的人。
而且关于她获得奥斯卡奖那一篇吧 大概只写了五行。
非常的淡然
跟诺兰的合作就写了半句。
对对对 完全和电影无关。
所以大家如果抱着这种期待 就不要翻开这本书。
那马修麦康娜是怎么给自个这本书定位的。
她说这不是一本传统意义上的回忆录。
我的确会讲述过去的故事。
但我对绝大多数回忆录中必有的怀旧伤感。
或者是退隐情绪毫无兴趣。
这是一本方法之书。
这是一本战术手册 基于我人生中的冒险。
她希望这本书能给大家在必要的时候。
能提供一些价值和宽慰和指导。
但是能不能提供指导呢？
这可能每个人看完会自由说法。
大概就是这样一本书这里边讲了她的故事。
主要是在于她人生很多的十字分岔路口。
她是怎么做决定
她是为什么要做出这样的决定。
她的犹豫徘徊 她的那种怯诺她都会写。
主要是在写 为什么叫绿灯我自己理解。
就是她人生很多的重大的事项的转折时候。
她以为自己通不过去。
后来她通过了有的是好运 有的是自己的思考。
反正她穿过去了大概就是这么个故事吧？
我稍微补充两句
这本书除了我们现在读到的文字版之外。
其实她在美国出版的时候有个有声书版本配套的。
然后这有声书版本是马修麦康纳自己朗读的。
所以大家如果感兴趣的话。
也可以去找一找有声书版本。
听听她自己读出来是什么样的效果。
因为我们现在读的是中文的一本。
也许跟她英文原文的还是有一些些区别的。
这本书除了刚才前面超哥介绍的这些部分之外。
它里面有一个我自己感觉到挺有特色的部分。
它里面有很多除了正文之外的拼贴。
我理解这个拼贴应该是从她之前一直在坚持写日记。
从那个日记里边摘出来的某一段。
然后把它放成这种拼贴式的方式在书里面给大家呈现。
好具
这个拼贴的部分就特别像金句。
特别像有折丝的那种东西。
我有时候看的时候多看几遍才能理解。
但是正文其实写的还是非常顺畅的。
而且里面有一些小幽默什么在。
读起来还是非常的顺的。
对
聊这本书之前我们先聊个小题外话。
首先咱们不是一直也没读过这类型的书吗？
我不知道为啥咱就没读。
然后以及你们俩平时有读这种名人专辑的习惯。
你们读这种专辑对他的期待或者预期是啥。
以及你们觉得衡量这类书写的好语不好。
那根你们自己的那根金线是啥。
我特好奇这个问题。
大老师先聊聊呗
我不知道你平时有读这种的书的习惯吗？
我读的非常少
但是我最近看的是冯晓刚的一本旧书。
回忆录
对回忆录叫不省心还是叫什么？
还有我把青春献给你。
我把那两本书给看。
我看他的专辑非常具体的目标。
就是我想知道幕后都发生了点什么事。
我是还是对那个幕后感兴趣。
比如说他当年拍什么一声叹息拍假方一方。
然后跟王硕的关系。
这些是因为我们基于一个作品。
有那种八卦之心
然后回去看
他的确会写到很多事情。
我对他写事这个东西会比较感兴趣。
因为我觉得很多名人专辑都有一个逃不开的一个套路。
就是我是怎么成功的。
对吧？
或者是说我是怎么克服那个失败的。
他会有一种炫耀感。
或者是后验的经验在。
我很抵触那个
因为我总担心那样的经验。
会给人带来一些不切实际的安慰或者指向。
就说我也像他这么做。
那我是不是能好一些呢？
或者是我是不是能达到他那个目标呢？
就这种过于具体的指向。
会让我比较警惕
所以我在看类似于这样的作品的时候。
我其实不太喜欢看他们是怎么成功的。
那完了
这本书就是在你不喜欢的点上。
这个书呢？
他还另外有一个不一样的。
一会再说
还有一种书的传记的问题。
尤其是欧美很多写作。
很容易就是写成一个学术论文。
学术综书
这个人他祖父是干什么的。
我看过很多书都是。
从祖父开始写
从上三代开始写
然后写的爸爸是干嘛的。
然后写他还是干嘛的。
写得非常没有人情味。
很像一个论文体
我看那些我就特别枯燥。
因为一是我们对那段人家国外的历史的历史。
其实没那么熟悉
也没那么感兴趣
然后里边一堆人名我又记不住。
所以就特别痛苦
而且人名还都差不多都一样。
对包括像什么？
乔普斯传的作者是不叫伊萨克森。
我又想不起来了
说错了大家
这种大部头的传记。
总会给我一种特别强烈的压迫感。
就是有历史的压迫。
有他那个成功过于幸运偶然的压迫。
我就不愿意看
然后今天这本书呢？
就是马兴麦康奈这个书。
我觉得他取在一个中间状态。
就是首先我就没那么喜欢。
这是我的确明书
然后其次是
我觉得他好在是没有那么具体的指向。
就说我是怎么拍这个片怎么成功的。
反而会给了我们一些抽象进入他的可能性。
我相信很多
就是特别看完很有感触的朋友。
也许真的就是遇到了。
一些人生的转折路口的时候。
你去看他
或者是你对自己接下来的这个决定。
非常犹豫的时候
去看这类的书
是能给一些自己的心理暗示的。
就是他肯定不能给你指向。
到底怎么做
但是他可能会让你内心的选择。
略加坚定
或者是说马兴麦康奈也和你一样。
犹豫和脆弱过
不知道怎么弄过
对
然后呢？
我想你之前我看那个。
众清翻译那本创意行为那个书。
就是李克鲁斌吧？
就写创意工作
写创意怎么做内容啊？
他是一个音乐人嘛？
去写这本书
然后那个书
其实问题就非常抽象。
他绝对不是教你什么怎么用。
什么编曲软件
或者是说怎么做一个播客。
什么这种不是这种操作手册。
而是一种
真的还挺抽象的
就类似于说什么？
就是感受宇宙间的能量。
类似于这种东西
然后你我一边看呢？
我一边就皱眉头
就说
这哥们真的得起到这个程度吗？
但是也有很多做内容的同行。
包括我们身边的朋友。
是非常喜欢和认可这本书的。
然后有的时候我会回去翻看。
就是当我真的遇到了某些。
做内容的具体的问题的时候。
也许真的他就有点像那个答案之书。
就是你随便翻开一页。
然后你就看这一段。
你看完这一段你会发现说。
好像是跟我说的
跟我想的那个问题有点挂烈。
就是这种感觉
所以我相信这个书。
他跟我们之前读的大量的文学作品。
文学写作完全不一样。
然后他跟之前那种。
论文式的宗术式的事物剧系的。
把这人六度分割都写完了的。
那种历史大部头传记也不一样。
然后他又是一个个人的。
带着一些
可以说是千碑的心态。
千碑的姿态去写的这么一本书。
他比较特别
然后我在看完整个书的时候。
我也会觉得
不像我期待的那样。
说写了很多幕后
我一直想说
哥们你拍那个《星际穿越》
我最喜欢的那场戏。
就是怎么拍的
对 怎么拍的
就是他面对那个镜头。
他已经穿越了几十年。
然后看见他的女儿已经老了。
比他现在还老的时候。
他的流眼泪那个独角戏。
对吧？
那一场戏应该是影视级别经典的戏。
我就特别想知道
你跟诺兰合作
你从一个积极无名的人。
到世界级的这种影帝。
你是怎么看表演的。
或者说这些大导演。
他们有什么齐伦意识。
我是抱着这个看八卦的形态来看。
他完全没有满足我这一套。
然后最后中间的那些。
插入的好词好剧
我好多我都略过了说实话。
就是我觉得
不是我现在这个状态能消化的。
因为我现在的确好像。
没有太多关于人生的问题。
如果真的是
对现在自己当下的处境。
有一些怀疑
有一些不确定的朋友。
看这本书
我相信可能会得到更多的启发吧？
星光呢？
对
我觉得确实个人专辑。
尤其是名人专辑的作品。
我们确实聊得非常少。
除了那本崔佛儿的专辑之外。
但是我觉得
如果放宽一些标准。
就像大老师说的
把回忆录这种体裁也纳入进来的话。
其实咱们读过的就更多一些。
比如说
陈冲老师的猫鱼就属于回忆录。
对吧？
包括咱们上一期节目鱼不存在。
也是有回忆录的性质在的。
还有以前咱们读过的好多书。
比如说
如何捉掩鼠
像成南旧市
巨刘河
我们撒
就是你讲的事吗？
对
这些都是关于一个人生的故事的。
这种讲述
回忆录式的方式
还有慈威格的人类群星闪耀时。
它就更贴近
是关于别人的名人的一个专辑。
但我觉得不管是
这严格的名人专辑也好。
还是回忆录也好
如果我们把这些作品的内核。
都看成是讲故事的话。
那其实跟我们
经常读的很多非虚构作品。
小说作品
就有一种内在的一致。
那为什么我觉得
我们比较少
涉及这种正经的名人专辑。
我个人认为
其中有一个比较重要的原因。
是虽然他们内在都是讲故事。
但是我在读专辑的时候。
心里面总是会有一个期待的。
就是我这个期待
我老想的
我读到的得是真的故事。
一个真实的人生
是不能够做任何虚假的成熟的。
也是不能够被粉饰的。
或者更进一步说
我希望它是有深度的。
并且对我有启发
我才愿意去读
否则我们说
读一个哪怕是名人的专辑。
那跟我又有什么关系呢？
就是我建立不起这种勾连。
因为有了上面的这些预期。
所以当我再翻开一本。
名人专辑的时候
我就会有一些障碍。
或者说尺处
如果是第三方的写作。
比如说是一个大作家。
一个记者
一个编辑
他去记录和写
一个名人的专辑
那我也许会因为
这个作家或编辑的身份。
对他有些信任感
就我会觉得
他可能写的是比较真实的。
他的资料整理
他的参考的爬书
都是比较全面的
能够真实的记录
一个人的一生
并且写出一些
对我们有意的东西。
但是对于那些自传体的。
传记来说
这种要求和预期
就会变得更高
我会天然地产生一种疑问。
就是说这是你自己写的。
你能写的真吗？
你会写出那些
不想让别人知道的。
难以其齿的
你内心当中的
真实的想法
而且有一句
古希腊的名言
大家都知道
就是认识你自己
一个人认识自己
是非常难的一件事。
那这个时候
你还是要让他写一本。
转记讲自己的人生故事。
那不就更是难上加难吗？
所以叠加起这些预期。
和这种疑问
我对这种名人转记。
就会有一种天然式的。
你不能说排斥吧？
就是可能会
稍稍有一些晚久欲。
对
并且我们每一个读者。
在读这种转记类作品的时候。
我觉得会有一种
比较天然的倾向
就是不管是
第三方写的
还是自己写的
我们在读的时候
都会想要看到
某种结论式的
或者是
概观定论式的东西。
因为我们在
纵观一个人的一生当中。
他做的种种事情的时候。
我们在观察他的时候。
我们会不由自主的。
用自己的世界观
价值观去套用
和评判这个人
就哪怕我们
在读的时候告诉自己。
别诈之别人
但是会或多或少的。
带入一些来自于
时代的
个体的价值观上
甚至道德上的一些倾向。
我觉得这是
难以避免的事
然后咱们
因为读过很多的作品。
所以你越读这些作品。
你越会感觉到
这个世界是很多元的。
人是很复杂的
所以咱们在
选题的时候
就不太想把那些
特别主观的感受和观点。
放到一个具体的人身上。
然后去评判他
去对他所做的事
对他的生活
说三道四
品头论足
比如说我们今天
读了《麻修麦康》
然后我们聊《麻修麦康》
的时候
我们会说
他做过什么事
我觉得这个事怎么怎么样。
就会叠加一些
我们对他的看法
就这样的事
可能不是咱们三个人。
特别想在节目当中。
呈现出来的
所以我觉得这也可能是。
我们不太会选
个人专辑
尤其是名人专辑的一个。
比较重要的方面
然后这儿
叠个假
如果听我们这期节目的朋友。
有特别喜欢
《麻修麦康》的朋友。
就不要太敏感
听到这期节目的时候。
就我们也很喜欢
《麻修麦康》
就先叠个假
对
所以我觉得这可能是。
我们很少去选
这种专辑类作品
去读的一个原因
与此同时
我觉得我对这类作品的。
预期和所谓金线
评价它好坏的标准。
也跟我的那份担忧。
是有关系的
因为我首先希望
它肯定是真实的
我们在看它的时候。
这种真实感
应该怎么去体现呢？
如果是第三方写的。
我们可能会看
它的参考资料
是不是足够详实
它是不是有多方的考证。
多方的评判
如果是它自己写的。
我们就会看
它是否拿出了
自己过往的很多日记。
要书信
这些私人的资料
去做一些参考和佐证。
这都是让我们
可以去评判
但是超出这份
真实性之上的那些。
读属于它自己的所思所想。
那个是我们没有办法。
去评判的
我们说到底
也不知道它到底写的。
是不是它真正想说的话。
它是否对自己的
内心诚实
这个是读者
没有办法去判断的。
但是有一点
有一个角度
我觉得是可以切入的。
就是我们去看
它所写出来的这部分。
跟我们之间的关系。
作为读者
它是否写出了
跟我们能够
搭建起桥梁的
那部分东西
比如说
像前面超哥和大老师。
都提到的
他所经历的事情
他所遇到的那些困惑。
跟我们所经历的困惑。
是否相同
他的快乐跟我们的快乐。
在哪种程度上
在哪些层面上
在哪些程度上
是可以相似的
是可以比较的
我觉得一旦
有过这样的比较
我们就构建起了
我们跟这本书
跟这个名人
跟他的传记之间的关系。
是
我之前觉得咱们
不读这类型的书
有一个原因
可能就是
像星光刚才
举的那个照片上的例子。
就是我觉得
名人传记长期以来。
存在某一个
被污名化的点
就是我们看到机场。
摆的都是那样
省着名人
就是他
要么聚成功
他是一个大乐
他有无限的财富
无上的荣光
要过两天下架
或者是他是一个
政治名人
美国就特别爱出这种。
总统
开始写回忆录
对吧？
他都对你是特别成功。
他才出回忆录
好像我们对于这种。
成功都保持
某种警惕
或者书院
对
尤其是财富名人
然后我自己
是一个对人
特别感兴趣的人
你要真给我拿出来。
那些书给我看
我可能也能看进去。
我就很好奇
他们是什么？
让他们成为这类型的人。
所以就变成了
当我对一切人
都好奇的时候
其实也没有任何的。
评选标准
因为给我啥
我都能看
就算是没标准
然后我看
这本书的时候
恰巧我看了
另一本书
叫成长心理学
是一位叫自飞的老师。
写的
特早之前
出版社给我记得
我也没翻开
然后恰巧那天看
我就
我说这到底成长
怎么还有心理学
我就翻了翻
结果恰巧这两本书。
对照着看
我就看到了
绿灯这本书
让我喜欢的部分
就是这本书
我不知道马修麦康那。
是不是有意为之
但是如果这两本书。
对照着看
我真的是能看出来。
一个人的成长
这个成长心理学里边。
它其实就讲的
叫人格的成长
所谓人格成长
我以前老觉得
就是说
人格分为本我自我超我。
这东西它就写定了。
或者是说
你那个超我在成长。
因为你受的这个超。
我就是道德
对我自己的要求
那你可能随着
社会的变迁
你生活在社会里边。
你跟社会的日益的。
接触日益深厚
所以你的这个超
我可能在不断的变强。
因为它是靠文化
和后天滋养的
那你的本我
应该是不会变化的。
但是看这本书里边。
就是成长心理学告诉我。
其实整个你的本我。
和超我
整个贯穿人
重生到死的一生
然后再看
马修麦康娜
这本绿灯的时候
她讲了自己
从小到50岁的时候。
整个经历
我就好像
恰巧能从这个
旁观者的角度
看到了这个人的
本我和超我
他的这个变化的
一个过程
他可能不意识到
自己在变化
但他写的这些事
让我看到这个变化。
我觉得还挺妙的
我觉得至少
这本书给了我一个启示。
就是我们不能够
自我放弃
多大岁数
都有成长的可能吧？
所以我就看的
还挺来劲的
就两个对照的看
而且马修麦康娜
自己后面还写了一段。
也就是说
你看我20岁的时候。
都是在处理
什么样的议题
我30到40岁
在处理什么？
我现在40到50。
是在处理什么议题。
就是非常好的
扣到了成长心理学。
成长心理学里边
会讲说
人整个成长
面临的议题
那么几个
比如说
我们在面对
人生目标是什么？
我们怎么处理亲密关系。
我们应该如何思考。
做决定和行动
如何处理社会关系。
你看这整好
这几个主题
都是马修麦康娜
在自己的人生里边。
核心着重需要处理的问题。
我们待会分享的时候。
大家可以会发现
而且这个
成长心理学里边
还有一段我也特喜欢。
他意思就是说
什么是一个成熟的人。
一个成熟的人就是。
你要认定
没有人生中
哪一个选择是关键的。
就是不是说
你一个选择
助救了你的人生
你错过了这个选择。
和节点
你的人生就崩塌了。
完全改变了
但你看
马修麦康娜的书里边。
他有的时候
会显露出某种说
你看
我如果没选这条路。
走到那条路
我可能人生
就走不到今天了
这个地方
有一点点分歧
我觉得这也是
给我留出
思考空间的地方
就到底
是不是他的人生
就是因为错过了
让他没有成为坏人。
或者他走对的路
让他成为马修麦康娜。
我觉得这是
留给我自己的一个思考题。
那行呗
那我们接下来
就开始说说这本书。
这书叫绿灯
我想听听你们
是怎么理解这个绿灯的。
以及你们觉得
这里边
有没有什么让你们。
印象深刻的故事
或者节点
你觉得还挺好玩的。
我这本书
我看完
我会
好奇一个
他的写法
姿态的问题
就是最近
我也在尝试
做一些新的东西
我发现
他在写这本书的时候。
在面对谁写作这件事情。
让我很好奇
现在我们
比如说路波克的时候。
我默认的是
面对你俩在说话
就是我们有一个对象感在。
然后像
很多人演讲
或者偷偷演出
我面对1000人。
再讲一个段子
然后
当我们现在习惯了。
在网上
所有的表达
都是有对象的之后。
他就会进入一个
有点想
一个中性词
就是勾引
想勾引那个人来的那种。
状态
这一方面是说
我想跟对面这个人。
产生交流
这是一个勾字
然后另外
我们也会陷入一种。
不自觉的表演状态。
就是我要在网上表演出来一个。
被喜欢的人
受欢迎的人
这样的姿态
往往他会影响到
做内容
和比如说你写一个朋友圈。
我是不是为了这个。
更多点赞
而再写一个朋友圈。
这件事情
已经
他让我默认在这条路上。
已经走很远了
然后我
这几天
我在做这种
单口的内容的时候。
我会发现
我有点不太会
面向自己去说话
或者说是
面向纯粹的表达而写作。
但是这样的表达
他又不是一个指向。
虚空的东西
他不应该是那么的飘。
你这说的飘是什么意思。
飘就是
我觉得他创作者
和内容产生连接的时候。
那个连接到底是因为。
你跟内容本身发生关系。
还是你想讨好
那个内容背后的受众发生的关系。
哦
这就是你真的真心想表达的话。
想说的话
还是说我说这句话是为了。
为谁做的
让别人喜欢我
让别人觉得我更好。
这是一个背后
那个隐形的一个力量。
然后同时
再往后退一步
就是你会发现
就是我在做一个内容的时候。
如果不用你
不用想去试图
跟对面连接这件事情。
产生关系
已经非常非常难了。
我举一个例子
就比如说
马修麦康奈这本书里面。
他就很少说
你看到这
你会不会有什么感觉。
或者说
读书的你
读到这
我想跟你说一个什么事。
我这本书就是想跟你说一个什么？
什么问题
你会不会觉得我很棒。
对对对
类似于
类似于这样的
讨好勾引
都是我们现在在
所有的互联网上
内容上大量看到的。
那种模式
然后这种模式
他已经持续了
可能得有10年
或者几年了
然后再回头看
马修麦康奈这本书。
或者说我们回头
看一些相对于传统的。
现在都觉得
有点古典的内容
你会觉得
他是一个单独
丑立在这里的
一个城堡这件事情。
变得很少见了
对
所以在看这本书
我会意识到
那他在写这本书的时候。
他的那个姿态
其实是非常重要的。
就是你在面向谁来写作。
我相信马修麦康奈。
写这本书的时候
他应该没有太考虑说。
我作为一个奥斯卡影币。
我要给我的万千影迷写一本。
我是怎么变厉害的书。
而是变成了一个
更面向自我的
就是我怎么跟自己对话。
或者说是我就作为一个人。
我尽量客观地描述。
我自己走了
这么50年的这条路。
我去描述这条路
我就是这么过来的。
试图切断
连接的诱惑
现在其实变得
非常非常难
以及需要新的技巧。
是的
所以我看这本书
会有比较强烈的感觉。
是他很自觉的
或者说是他一定是有意识的。
做这件事
这件事没有那么容易。
我读这个书的时候。
因为我跟超哥一样。
我就觉得马修麦康奈。
是一个比较优秀的演员。
拿过奥斯卡奖
他演过一些非常优秀的电影。
我也很喜欢
但其实我对
除了他演过的电影之外的。
信息内容
我完全不知道
我也不知道他出身于什么？
我也不知道他的家庭状况。
也不知道他经历过哪些。
我都不知道
但是
正是因为今天这本书。
他给了我一个新的认识。
在我心里
我一直觉得他是演技派。
但其实在他的演艺生涯之前。
他是有过奶油小生。
那个角色的那个派别。
时期的
就出演过很多浪漫戏剧。
对吧？
而且他都不是
科班出身一开始
他的人生从来
无至于当演员
那在这两个时期之间。
他有过一段折腐期。
这个折腐期在这本书里面。
也有很详细的描述。
他是怎么度过的
他是怎么想的
怎么坚持下来的
我在读这本书之前。
这些信息其实是不了解的。
相当于读了之后
给我了一个新的
对于马修买康那本人的认识。
除此之外
翻开这本书之前
我挺想从这本书里面。
去看看那些世俗当中。
已经功成名就的
像马修买康那这种明星。
想从他们的文字当中。
去看到
他们所遇到的那些问题。
他们人生当中
所经历的那些东西。
跟我到底一样不一样。
或者说
这些相似或不同的东西。
到底是来自于
他们的家庭
社会时代还是个体。
以及对于这种
功成名就的人
俗事意义上的成功人士来说。
他写这本资转
到底想干啥
他想表达什么？
他的这种表达
对我到底有没有意义。
对我到底有没有价值。
因为我知道
即便我读完这本书。
我也不可能
成为下一个马修买康那。
我不可能通过
读这本书去学他
成为他
就不可能
我甚至于不可能
在这辈子成为一个演员了。
那么他在这本书里。
所写到的这些经验经历。
对我是不是还有参考性。
这是我翻开这本书。
之前的一个预期和问题。
读完之后
我觉得部分满足了我的预期。
或者说部分回答了。
我的这些疑问
这怎么讲呢？
就是当我读完这本书之后。
我就会发现
抛离掉一切的身份。
标签 职业 成就 胎口 名利。
等等这些外在的东西以后。
所剩下的那部分
遇到的困惑
他和我遇到的是有相似性的。
比如说回归到最本质的问题。
对于很多人生大灾问的探寻。
我是谁 我从哪来。
我要到哪去
以及我想要什么？
我不想要什么？
等等这样问题的探索。
是他有的 我也有的。
但只是说
可能回归到俗事意义上的。
那些层面上不一样。
可能是我想要什么？
我想要这个工作
还是那个工作
对于他来说
可能就是今天我读万豪。
还是读什么？
其他的大酒店
就是不太一样的
或者是我演这个戏。
还是接那个导演的戏。
接一个更赚钱的
接一个我更想演的角色。
是 是 是
世俗意义上的可能不一样。
但是抛离掉
所有世俗意义上的这些标签。
回归到本质去看
那个我想要什么？
和我不想要什么？
回答的那个问题
都是我是谁的问题。
我怎么样在这个世界上。
寻找我的位置的问题。
所以在这个通用的。
大灾问的问题上的相似性。
让他的这个自传
对我有一些小小的启发。
同时我发现
他也有这种问题的时候。
我就会有一些事然。
或者说安慰
原来这样的人也有这种问题。
他都那么有钱
那么有名
那么有成就了
也依然会遇到同样的问题。
这说明
这些本质上的问题。
人都差不多
对 而且他不是通过。
你有钱了
有名了有成就了
就能够得到解决的。
他有钱有名了
依然还会遇到这种问题吗？
那对于我来说
就是一个安慰
那我还招什么急呢？
是
这些问题不随着说。
等我哪一天怎么怎么招了。
这些问题就消失
不存在这个
不会解决
只是层次不一样了。
成就不一样了
那我为什么还要在我的生活当中。
去苦苦追寻
那个已经被证明
不能打开这些锁的那把。
不对的钥匙呢？
卖球买卡那已经给我们答案了。
就是我有钱了有名了。
这些钥匙打不开我现在这把锁。
那我为什么还要自以求的。
去执着的追求那些不对的钥匙呢？
读了这个书之后
就反而能让我用更平和的心态。
去面临这些
每个人都需要去回答的。
在自己人生当中
面临的这些问题
而且在这个书里面。
除了他提出问题
他也说了
他是怎么解决这些问题的。
当然了里面设计到一些。
玄学的层面
比如说做了个梦
去了趟非洲什么的。
这也设计到
你有没有条件去非洲。
没少做梦
做了好几个梦呢？
对有没有条件
通过这些方式
去解决你的问题
可能他的方法
不适用于每一个人。
但是也让我们知道。
他是有方法的
每一个人
我们需要找到
能打开你的那把锁的。
那把特别的钥匙
而不是说
我们看到说
可能有钱了
像大佬说的
我就能解决这些问题。
不能
马田麦康娜告诉你不能。
我说等我退休了
我就能怎么着怎么着。
是的不能
你依然还是要回答这些问题。
而且依然还是要找到。
自己那把钥匙
去打开你的那把锁。
我觉得这个是
这本书给我的一个。
观点上的非常好的启发。
我接着大佬说
这个书里边
让我挺感动的是
两个地方
一个地方是
就跟大佬说那个相关。
就是我们都知道
今天对于明星来说。
或者对于每个人来说。
我们都来到了一个。
必须政治正确的时代。
对吗？
而且像马向麦康娜。
身在美国的娱乐圈。
好莱坞他更是一个。
政治正确必须要
政治正确的重灾区。
而且像他这样的人。
我觉得他一定知道。
我怎么说是正确的。
但这本书里边
有非常多的
政治不正确的地方。
不是一个
今天意义上
被倡导的一个男性。
对吧？
果不其然
很多平台也说
这是一个
非常自恋的一个男的。
但是马向麦康娜
他没有做这些的妥协。
包括他的团队
也没有让他
不说这些东西
然后第二个
关于他家庭
他的父母
他的父母那些
相爱的方式
包括他的哥哥
那都是充满了
各式各样不正确
我相信
一定会有人跟他说。
你把这些写出来
会不会对你的家庭成员。
产生了很多的非议。
人们会不会
觉得他们是一个
不堪的人
比如说他父母
对他的教育
孩子就得打
我觉得我们的家庭。
打这件事就是对的。
在今天绝对是一个。
被人纸摘的
被人诟病的
这么一些行为
但是马向麦康娜
依然把这些东西
写出来了
我觉得
这就是让我
非常非常喜欢
他的地方
就是我们今天
太知道
如何说一些
华儿不时的废话
我都觉得
他不是讨好
不是取悦了
而是说
我只是不想让自己。
惹麻烦
今天
我们所有做公众
表达
要跟公众打交道的人。
他也知道
怎么做这件事了
但是为什么？
马向麦康娜
没有这么干
而且他的团队
也没有让他
把这些拿掉
就是我们以前
做公关
老跟明星打交道
你采访完之后
有一堆明星
来他的团队
说这你不能说
那不能说
这不能说
然后我就讲说
我们为什么今天
老觉得
很多的明星的
采访不好看
你会发现这些明星。
也没什么可谈的
你就看完这本书
就知道了答案
第一
这些我们的明星
确实也没有什么？
丰沛的生活
你看马向麦康娜
大火了之后
干嘛呢？
他感受到了
巨大的惶恐
然后他去
看着房车去旅行
他过了
三年的生活
是在房车上渡过的。
激流永退
我们今天知道了
非常多的
这些著名的电影
包括他
和斯比尔伯哥
合作的电影
就是他在
带着他的狗
生活了三年
那个过程当中
在路上坛城的
这不可思议
这对我们今天
中国的任何一个
明星来说
我一夜之间爆火
我怎么可能
慌慌张张的
逃开了
我必须接住
这波流量
对
恨不得我每天
不睡觉
我也把所有的东西。
都填满
我也得跟小红书
上直播卖货
是
然后马向麦康娜
干了什么？
他开始房车
去了热带雨林
去了南美
后来还去了非洲
去和不同的人
对
没有人知道他是谁。
然后这个有巨大的生活。
这个阶层之间的不匹配。
我们试问
今天中国哪一个明星。
敢说我火了之后
我去找一个村里边折腐。
恨不得就把我是谁。
我有多少粉丝
贴在脑门上
所以这也就是
为什么马向麦康娜。
可以演那么多的
人物角色
我们依然觉得
徐徐如生
就是他见过这些人。
他的生活
不可这些人
相处过
叫什么叫有生活
这个书就知道
你看马向麦康娜
对很多角色的塑造。
比如说
他要演一个
谈恋爱的
他的角色
人物的原型
来自于他的哥哥
他发现有一天
他跟他妈去学校里边。
接他哥
他哥在抽烟
在跟一个女孩儿聊天。
他其实那一场戏
他的灵感
就来自于他的哥哥。
我们不知道
今天的idol
你的生活都被
所有人都包围着
你去哪
他有机会谈恋爱吗？
他都没谈过恋爱
他怎么演
暗恋别人
就跟办公室
拿着文件撞一满怀。
然后帮人剪文件
就是恋爱了
回到开始
那个问题
为什么我们说
现在很多明星的
访谈不好听
第一个就是
他没有什么人生
真实的经历
你没有经历过
任何事情
但是你非要
救你的人生经历
发表一些感悟和看法。
从何而来呢？
你就觉得他
很须悬俘
这是第一个
第二件事就是
我们被
必须要正确
这个紧咕咕咕了
你也不敢表达
本来你就没有
结果你还不敢
就基本上
我请你来
你既没有故事
你也没什么想说的。
那有什么可聊的呢？
他不好听
不好听
那就变成说
那就是因为他有名。
请来
所以我最近看很多的。
这个所谓叫明星访谈。
我真的就是
执着牙花子
我说为什么要请他来。
如果他不有名
他没有这些Title。
他就说这些话
老师您邀请他来吗？
所以在这个时候
我就觉得
啪啪叫
真的是一个
值得我们学习的人。
你看人啪啪叫
请的谁
都是那些
所谓叫没有名的人。
那可不嘛？
人家知道
我要的是表达对象。
要的是一个会讲
故事的人
而不是所谓的
带着光环来的人
所以我就看这本书的时候。
就联想起了很多
内心非常复杂
我们为什么说
今天的
我们的内容都完蛋。
一方面
大家都赖环境
我们要试问
大家做内容的人
您有没有
要不要为今天
这个内容生态
走到今天
负一份责任
现在没有存在
那种单纯的表达了。
所有的表达
后边都有一下一步。
就是我要跟对面那个人。
产生连接
是什么圈子也好
让对面的人欣赏我也好。
让对面的人恨我
或者骂我也好
都存在于
那个第三阶段
就是我要跟那个
内容的受众发生关系。
但是
流量裸探
马修麦康娜这本书。
或者说我们再回忆一些。
曾经那些我们小时候看的。
就是古典的叙事
一个作者
表达完之后
这件事就结束了
他不可控
他也不指向任何东西。
他甚至没有任何期待。
他也没有办法做那些期待。
你说当年
没有互联网的时候。
没有社交媒体的时候。
这些作家们
写一本书
或者拍了一个电影出来。
他就是扔出去了
就不管了
就管不着了
但是现在的创作逻辑。
完全反过来
所以说
这个市场现在喜欢什么？
什么对 什么正确。
什么火
我们来创作吧？
我们来按着那个创作吧？
所以现在的创作逻辑。
早就变了
然后这种变化
它就是潜移谋化的。
让所有人
就刚才超哥说
不光是明星
我觉得所有人
我们都陷入了那种。
表演状态
然后真正纯粹的表达。
我们似乎已经不会做了。
就是那个表演和表达。
它就像一个
寄生双生关系一样。
它就彼此寄生在一起。
你想把它切开
你想把那个表演
摘掉这件事
已经变得很难
对 它内化在你的能力里边了。
对 它内化了
或者说它已经
就是让你在你的一篇文章里面。
摘不掉你这个字
这现在就是我的问题。
我就会遇到这样的问题。
这是我本人的困惑。
就是如果你写一篇文章。
你写一个稿子
这里边没有你
你没有那个对面
假设的人
你都不会表达这件事。
你就不知道
这事该怎么说
所以这件事情就变得。
让我个人非常的有感触。
然后我也想试图
去跟这个问题
稍微去拧摆一下
当然我也不是说
我一定能做得多好。
或者我就怎么着了。
而是说
那我还能往回退一步吗？
我还能回到那个
纯粹为了表达
而表达的那个自我。
那个自我还在吗？
接下来
未来这几十年
未来的时代里面
可能所有人
也许就不再区分这件事了。
就是表演和表达
它就是一个事
所有的表达都是表演。
所有的自我
在互联网上呈现出来的作品。
都跟我试图想去连接。
什么人想去吸引
什么人想去赚什么钱。
密切相关
那这件事
是不是一个好事
我不知道
我只能说
现在让我感受到了某种不适应。
不会了
有点
我听你们俩谈
这个就让我联想起来。
最近特别热的一件事。
就是张雪机车
他不是拿了那个
摩托车大赛的冠军吗？
这个时候我还以为。
你要说宋宁峰出轨呢？
没少吃瓜呀大老师。
是给我忙的
这几天我看不过来了。
张雪这个事就印证了。
你们俩刚才说的那个。
就是当一个人
没有取得所谓的成功。
或者没有取得所谓的名声。
没有流量聚集的时候。
我们就不会去关注他。
甚至也不会去关注他之前的事。
你看他20年前
在湖南卫视
有一个节目采访他。
当时特别年轻
他追着那个记者说。
我要上你们电视
展示一下我的摩托车技能。
然后追了人家
三小时
就一定要让人家拍他。
然后各种失败
就是那个时候
我们所有人
你回想一下
20年前
我们看这个电视的时候。
我们看到张雪这样的一个人物形象。
我们心里面是什么样的评价。
我们会对他有什么评价。
以及20年之后
当我们看到他取得了。
现在的世俗意义上的成功之后。
我们再回头去看
他当年的拍下来的那个东西。
我们又会有
什么样不一样的感受。
我觉得这就是
不同的时代下
我们对这个所谓表达。
或者说流量逻辑
不同的观感
这是不一样的
就是我们
只有当一个人
有这个流量的时候。
我们才会去追溯
他以前曾经说过什么？
看到过什么？
如果他没有成为
那个流量的封口的时候。
我们可能都
根本不会去关心他。
他是谁
我们平面关心你
就是他连成为一个笑话的。
资格都没有
对 或者说
他以前所做过的一切努力。
一切事情
在他没有被流量推起来的。
那个当下
是没有意义的
就是不管是好是坏。
是正面是负面
都没有意义
那我们就要考虑
是不是我们把流量这件事情。
前置了
就是现在所有的
不管是表达
还是表演的东西
都会把流量至于
所有的这个事情之前。
我们去考虑这个事。
对
拉回来这本书
我们分享这些书里边。
来精彩的内容
好
我分享一个
后面第六章
他说这一章叫做
见不寻把
把引见
这应该是那个
见书与缠薪里面的。
一个核心观点
就是
他说
我是个成功的演员。
机身名流
头戴明星光环
我不必为公养家人。
或支付房租而劳神。
但我的职业生涯
那些找上门来
和我正在拍摄的
角色和电影
已经不能再满足我了。
我已经厌倦了
浪漫喜剧中的角色。
以及这些角色
所在的世界
长期以来
一直处于一种
隔削骚扬的状态
但是
我的生活非常充实。
狂野
刺激
本真
深刻而充满了生机。
我笑得更开怀
哭得更动情
爱得更深
恨得更切
相比于我在电影中。
扮演的任何角色
我在生活中真实的样子。
更能让我全心认同。
我明白
在生活和事业
有所测重是不可避免的。
生机薄薄的生活
要比征征日上的事业。
更加重要
但是
我仍想参与那些
至少能够为我
当下的生活
带来不同色彩的故事。
扮演那种
至少能挑战
现实生活中
那个生龙活虎的
我的角色
然而
那些我在寻找的
能够与我的
现实生活
评分秋色的角色
和故事在哪呢？
他们并没有主动登门。
就像我在上文所说的。
那些主动登门的
角色和故事
却无法让我问心无愧。
高枕无忧
是时候做出改变
调整方向
做出新的承诺了
我不再搬来搬去
体验新环境
不同气候
这一次
带着更加
丰沛的生活的使命。
我不能再给自己留退路。
是时候真正专注于自身。
看看我到底
能破腐成周到哪一步了。
是时候做出真正的牺牲了。
我分享这一段
我非常喜欢的一句就是。
说生机薄薄的生活。
要比真正日上的事业。
更加重要
即便是马修麦康娜这样的人。
我们说了一万遍
就是他这么有钱
他这么有名
他想什么似乎都能得到。
但是他依然会有那个。
工作和生活
要如何平衡的问题。
然后他的工作
是否能满足他的生活。
这个和他的什么名气。
得过多少奖
其实没有任何关系。
就是所有人做内容。
创作
或者是你去做一件事情。
都会存在
就是你厌倦了
当下的状态
你要怎么去寻找
一种新的刺激
这种新的刺激要怎么来呢？
马修麦康娜
他只是一个容器
他只是把这个问题。
放在他这个容器里面。
形成了一个他的形状。
但是这个问题
对于每个人来说
都是真实的
所以就这本书
一定能在其中的
某一两句话
感受到
这个好像跟我当下的生活。
是有所挂裂的
或者是跟你做的事情。
跟你做的内容是相关的。
我就是会在
不经意间遇到这样的小瞬间。
这个是对我蛮感动的。
我分享一个
在书里面
他讲自己的经历里面。
有很多特别幽默的部分。
而且这些部分
让我们读起来的时候。
会觉得挺有意思的。
会心一笑
就是他前面讲小时候。
分享他妈妈
关于他妈妈的一个事。
他讲说
没有人能像我母亲。
那么快原谅自己
因此
他没有任何精神负担。
我曾经问过他
会不会带着遗憾上床。
他很快回答到
儿子
我每天晚上都带着。
遗憾上床
只是一醒来就全忘了。
他总是告诉我们
每到一个地方
不要表现的
想把这地方买下
而是拿出一副
你就是这里的主人的样子。
雾雍坠言
夜死
是他最喜欢的英文单词。
1977年
我母亲为我报名
参加了在德克萨斯。
尼德拉举行的
小小德克萨斯先生比赛。
我赢回了一座大奖杯。
母亲为这张照片
箱了框
把它挂在厨房的墙上。
我每天早上
来迟早饭时
他都会直指奖杯说。
你可真棒 冠军
1977年
小小德克萨斯先生的冠军。
去年
在他的剪辑本上
偶然看到这张照片时。
有什么东西
引起了我的注意
出于好奇
我在电脑上
把奖杯上的名牌放大。
上面刻着的
竟是亚军
在主同适应方面
左相批谜
我拨通了他的电话。
问到
妈 一直以来你都说。
我才是小小德克萨斯先生。
原来我只是亚军
他回答说
不对
赢冠军的那个孩子。
家里比咱们有钱
他们为了比赛
专门给他买了一套。
高级的三件套礼服。
这就是作弊
你才是小小德克萨斯先生。
这一段让我觉得
他们还真是挺幽默的。
而且这种
我觉得性格
或者说
形式的思考的逻辑。
其实从小也影响了。
马修买康娜
他在思考一些事情上。
尤其是
我觉得对于这样的事。
他有一种特别的适然感。
虽然不是冠军
但是我可能能从
另外一个角度去思考。
我不是冠军的原因是什么？
然后对自己有一份安慰。
或者说他妈妈
在他从小的时候
给他了一种信心
一直管他叫冠军
也让他一直以为
自己是小小德克萨斯的冠军。
这个我觉得也是
在教育方法上
可能会有一些启发的地方。
然后同时
关于他母亲和父亲的逻辑。
在这个书里面
有非常详细的描述。
有一张专门叫
网命之图的逻辑
就是他接受到的很多。
从小的教育和我们。
贯场所认为的
可能有点不太一样。
比如说
那可太不一样了
对
比如说他跟他父亲。
有一回讲到
就是他偷披萨的那件事情。
也是
我觉得特别有代表性。
有一天
他父亲接到一个电话。
是他的朋友打过来的。
他的朋友跟他父亲说。
我和马修买康娜
一起去披萨店
然后吃了披萨
但是没付钱
于是他父亲
回来问
马修买康娜这件事。
他是这么写的
他说
爸爸平静的把双手。
放在膝盖上
仰起下吧？
看着我的眼睛
这是我看到他的牙齿。
仅仅咬在了一起
我再问你一次
儿子
你是有意偷披萨的吗？
我只需回答一句
是的爸爸
我是有意的
这样一来
他只会迅持我坏事。
做的不够整密
被人捉了个正着
然后因被人抓住这事。
拿皮带抽我几下屁股。
但是
我偏偏没有这么做。
我瞪大了眼睛
牛仔裤的当部
我姐姐爸爸的回答。
不是的爸爸
我说过了
怕父亲从床上一跃而下。
右手握拳
哼哼打在我脸上
让我那卑微的啃球。
夹然而止
我跌倒在地
与其说是因为吃了拳头。
不如说是因为我那两条。
因胆怯惊恐
而鸡满了乳酸的腿。
掺扯微微站不住了。
我这是罪有应得
就由自取
自作自受
作简自负
自取其货
这惩罚是我应得的。
我对父亲撒了谎
这伤透了他的心
对他来说
偷披萨不是什么大事。
在此之前
他偷过很多披萨
日后也没有金盆洗手。
我只要承认就万事大吉了。
但是我没有这样做。
你看这个就是他所说的。
那个逻辑
跟我们所贯常接受的。
完全不一样
我们会说
你不能偷东西
偷东西才是大事
但他爸说
你偷了不承认
才是大事
是的
这个就是
非常不一样的地方。
我读到这个时候
觉得这个挺有意思的。
这个逻辑跟我们
确实不太一样
我分享这两段吧？
就是星光分享那个。
我也特想分享
我从这里边学到了。
很多跟孩子教育相关的。
我给大家先念一段。
然后再说两个其他的。
我分享这一段
是写在书的开头
我还给铁锤
在我们家大声朗读了一遍。
就是这样写的
他说
我来自一个充满爱的家庭。
我们或许并不总是喜欢彼此。
却永远深爱彼此
我们拥抱
亲吻
摔角
打架
我们不会把怨恨埋在心里。
在我的先人中
有很多破坏分子
这些持有自由主义理念的。
亡命之徒
通过投票
将叛军驱逐出去
为的是削减
入侵领土的
其他亡命之徒的势力。
我出身于一个
规矩分明的家庭
在这里
在你有足够的勇气。
和能力
去打破规则之前
还是安分守己为好。
在这里
父母说
因为大人说了算
那你就要照做
如若不然
等待你的不是近足。
而是皮带抽打
或是反手一记巴掌。
因为这能更快的
让你认识到错误
也不会占用你
最宝贵的资源
破之后
时间
在我家里
受完体罚之后
父母会立马
带你穿过全城
去你最喜欢的
知识汉堡和乃西店。
庆祝你吸取了教训。
如果你违反了规矩。
父母有可能会惩罚你。
但如果你被人
抓了个正着
他们便百分之百
会狠狠教训你
即使皮操肉后
我们也知道
对我们而言
只是脑养羊斑的问题。
往往足以给
其他人造成创伤
因为遇到问题
我们要么应对
要么否认
我们的家人
是最不会在恶孕面前。
哭爹喊娘的人
这是一种哲学
让我成了一个
既扎实肯干
又狡猾精明的人
我勤奋肯干
也喜欢耍些忌量
而这种哲学
同时也带来了
一些寇人
新鲜的精彩故事
这是我先分享这段。
后边还有两个例子。
他们家有三个男孩。
马修麦康娜说
我们每一个男孩
都有一个成人礼
这个成人礼是怎么回事。
他先讲他大哥的成人礼。
他大哥的成人礼
他有一天
成为一个特别厉害的销售。
而且挣了很多钱
然后他爸
就说
晚上要去偷东西
偷滚到
偷的是谁呢？
就是偷的
他哥的那个
大客户家的东西
他哥说不能偷
他爸就跟他的哥打起来。
而且是真打架
就是他爸是用拳头。
他哥用那个大木头板子。
打他爸
然后他哥甚至以为。
会把他爸打死了
然后这个时候
他爸站起来说
儿子今天你成人了。
就完成了成人礼
因为你有能力
干败我了
我尊重你
就真的是赢得尊重。
然后第二件
他二哥的成人礼
更逗
就是他爸喝完酒
在酒吧里边
跟人比赛
比谁尿得高
然后他爸失败了
然后他爸跟那个人说。
你等着把我儿子
搬救兵去
对
而且他爸搬救兵
可不是回家
他爸是开车
往返300公里
气性太大了
太赢了
先开180公里回家。
然后把他儿子拉来。
然后尿尿尿高了之后。
再把他儿子送回去。
就是我当时
看到这个地方
真的是又觉得好笑。
然后又觉得有点道理。
就是这跟我们今天。
实下流行的教育观点。
截然相反
比如说体罚孩子
这里边讲的说
我们家的规矩就是。
你犯了错误
我就要揍你
比如说他说脏话
父母会拿肥皂泡洗他的嘴。
这在今天
我们觉得说
这简直就是体罚
会不会给孩子留下阴影的。
怎么能这么干呢？
对吧？
然后包括说
你破坏了规矩
我就揍你
因为这让你省时间。
打完你之后
我还带你去吃好吃的。
我们觉得
这什么家庭疯了吗？
这会不会让孩子造成疮伤。
但是你看马修麦康娜。
是怎么来写这些事情的。
到底有没有给他留下疮伤。
其实我是觉得
马修麦康娜对于父母。
到后来
他是有非常深刻的感激的。
所以就是我们今天太讲。
就说你教育孩子
要温柔而坚定
你不能干这些阅举的事。
不能打孩子
打孩子简直是疯了。
要被怎么着
但是这个事让我知道了。
最重要的不是方法。
而是我们是不是能够。
在孩子面前
呈现真实的感情
我那天看了小红书。
有一个铁的
有一个老师说
说我见了太多的家长。
说我只希望我的孩子快乐。
健康就好
但是你真的孩子
拿一三十分的券回去。
你看他们还会不会这么说。
你呈现的不是真实的关系。
就是你嘴上说
你只要快乐做你自己。
但是你违逆了我
我依然还是要用
变着farer
让你改变
让你按照我的规则行径。
就这种方式
和马修麦康娜父母说。
不朽规则
就要受到惩罚
你看这是
两种截然不同的方式。
那到底哪个是正确的。
我觉得每个家庭和每个孩子。
都有自己的相处方式。
但真正最重要的是。
你们之间
到底那个真实的感情。
是不是存在
你是不是真的爱他。
就是你要传达给他什么东西。
这是更重要的
是的
而且就是每个孩子。
都有自己的生活方式。
每个孩子都有自己的性格。
我觉得这是我们今天的。
所谓的育儿
走入了一个误区
放之四海而皆准
对 放之四海而皆准的道理。
用这个道理
就能把每一个人交成。
一样的完美一样的好。
我觉得根本不存在。
人是个复杂的东西。
我们要留存很多复杂的方式在。
然后包括我那天看。
李孙伟老师
他在自己公众号里写说。
为什么？
我们看似今天的孩子。
这么复杂
我们父母
经常让孩子做好多选择。
你要干这个还是干那个。
请你来选
你上钢琴班
还是语文班
对
他说选择太多
对于孩子不是个好事。
因为孩子很小的时候。
他根本没有选择的能力。
你给他了很多的自由和选择。
对他来说是一种负担。
而且没有什么选择是完美的。
是对的
我们现在最大的问题。
在于你有了那么多信息。
就让你以为我可以选择。
一个最正确的东西。
其实没有什么？
所谓叫最正确的选择。
人生是在不同的一个选择。
累积之上
才形成了所谓的一条道路。
但是我们现在的问题。
老是说
我得看穷尽所有的信息。
判断做出一个最有利的选择。
我觉得就是看完这本书里边。
很多的教育你会发现。
没有最正确的选择。
最重要的是
你是不是坚决执行贯彻那个。
你认为最值得选的那个东西。
这个才是最重要的。
那我们再来一轮短的吧？
这回星光先来
我来分享一段就是。
前面不是说过吗？
马修买康那
有过几段演艺生涯的时期。
有一段时期
是他出演了很多部浪漫喜剧片。
所以他有一个那种浪漫小声的。
这么一个形象
但是后来他决定说。
我自己真正想要的是什么？
我要成为一个演技派。
我要在屏幕上塑造的形象到底是什么？
那他就想要转型
于是他就拒绝了那个时候。
很多对他发出邀请的。
同样的浪漫喜剧片类型的。
这样的一个拍摄的邀约。
然后在拒绝的时候。
他相当于折服了好长时间。
他坚持着
一定要挑到自己满意的剧本。
才重新出山
然后来演他想要演的角色。
那在这个相当于
好莱坞是一个如此功利的环境。
如果你很长时间不出现在大家面前。
可能就会被渐渐遗忘。
那你也许就这辈子都出不来了。
那在这种情况下
他怎么去抵抗这种诱惑。
说我要坚持的选自己。
要演的角色
不遇到好的剧本
我就坚决不出来
哪怕我可能要面临一辈子。
都出不来的状况
我也要这样坚持
他在这段过程当中的描述。
有一段特别有意思。
他讲说
一年过去了
浪漫喜剧的邀约
铺天盖地的送上门来。
但是找到我的只有浪漫喜剧片。
出于尊重
我一一读过这些剧本。
但我坚持不懈
守住了自己的承诺。
最终把这些邀约
稀术拒绝
想要知道我有多么坚决吗？
有一部片子出价500万美元。
让我花两个月拍摄。
我读了剧本
选择了拒绝
然后对方又出价800万美元。
拒绝
接着他没有给出
1000万美元的价格。
谢谢好意
这次读来
他没有加码到1250万美元。
还是不行
但是非常感谢
最后对方开出了1450万美元。
让我再读一遍剧本。
你们猜怎么着
这次读来
剧本竟然比之前显得精彩了。
更加有趣
更有戏剧冲突
与出价500万美元时。
我所读到的剧本相比。
整体质量都上了一个档次。
实际上剧本并没有变。
里面的字句完全相同。
但质量的确远超我。
之前收到的那些剧本。
我还是选择了拒绝。
如果我无法做自己想做的事。
无论出价高低
我都不会勉强自己去做。
不想做的事
这段里面有一个情绪的起伏。
我觉得特别有意思。
就是人们对方不断的加价码。
加到1450万美元的时候。
他又读里面的剧本。
觉得那个剧本比之前读的。
竟然更好
其实剧本没有任何的改变。
但就因为前述上出现了变化。
导致这个情绪上的变化。
我觉得这个特别真实。
就是我们会知道
这个选择影响你的抉择的因素。
有很多
其中金钱的回报
这个影响是非常大的。
从马修买康纳的实力上。
我们也能看到
500万美元跟1450万美元的差距。
就是你会觉得剧本。
整体上了一个档次。
但其实都是一样的东西。
但是后面他又写到说。
即便如此
他还是选择了拒绝。
我觉得那句话特别好。
他说如果我无法做自己想做的事。
无论出价高低
我都不会勉强自己去做。
不想做的事
这个就证明他其实已经想清楚了。
他想做什么不想做什么？
以及在这个想做和不想做之间。
能够影响他抉择的那个因素有多重。
以及能够影响他这个抉择的因素。
到达一个什么程度。
才能够使他改变想法。
我觉得这是我们
每一个人可能在面临相似的问题的时候。
都要想清楚的问题。
就是你想要什么？
当你做选择的时候。
什么情况下
绿灯是为你量起的。
你要选择走哪个道路。
以及当你遇到红灯和黄灯的时候。
有哪些因素的改变。
会让这个红灯黄灯变成绿灯。
或者让绿灯变成红灯黄灯。
我觉得这些都是
我们在人生当中需要。
像马修买康娜一样。
遇到这些抉择的时候。
需要考虑到的
刚刚星光分享这段我也画了。
不是说马修买康娜。
就是一个特别坚定自我的人。
而是说你看他也比较幽默。
说这个提了价值之后。
剧本确实深刻了
我觉得所有的选择。
都有一个价格
我们人生的所有选择。
都在那个比价的过程当中。
就如果说这提升到2000万。
没准他就拍了
我觉得这没有
就是无可厚非
我们不能把一个
一个人对艺术的追求真空化。
就是说
他无论如何都不会去做这件事的。
你给的多少钱都没用。
往往在现实过程当中。
不一定是那么发生的。
即便是马修买康娜。
我觉得就是
这一段给我的感觉。
然后我分享一段
我最期待的就是
他写到跟诺兰的合作。
但是那就半句
然后这一段我觉得。
也写得挺有意思的。
在第八章
叫做《健行你的传承》
他说我马不停提的。
与克里斯多夫诺兰合作了。
《星际穿越》
与格斯凡桑特合作了。
《生命之树》与《盖斯罗瑞》
合作了《穷斯的自由国度》
与史蒂芬加翰合作了《金矿》
与杨德芒热合作了。
《白人男孩李克》
与史蒂芬奈特合作了《金韬迷局》
与哈莫尼克林合作了。
《海滩流浪汉》
与《盖里奇》合作了《深世门》
《深世门》也是一个。
非常厉害的电影
我相信很多朋友都看过。
另外为我的孩子
我还给几部动画片配了音。
《魔仙传说》
换了好声音
一和二
另外我还是
林肯汽车的品牌大使。
并成为一名
成功的汽车销售员。
同时还是野火机
播旁威士忌的创意总监。
所有这些
都是我渴望研究
投身并成为的角色。
所有这些都是
我觉得扣人心弦
别出心裁
值得讲述的故事
所有这些
都是我迁进不换的体验。
票房成绩却显有惊喜。
有什么东西
没有有效的传递出去。
我承制的邀请大众。
进场看电影
影院的座位
却还是有空的
问题出在我本人呢？
还是选题
或者电影本身呢？
是发行不利
一或是留年不利
要不就是时代不同啊？
我不确定
我猜这些原因
或多或少都有一点吧？
票房的惨担
并没有交灭
我对表演的喜爱
反倒让我更加
狂热地投入到
自己的事业中
我爱表演
我爱创造
我爱在角色中
迷失自我
再重新找到出路
我深深热爱沉浸
从内而外的
审视我的好兄弟
我享受为塑造
和成为我的好兄弟。
所付出的努力
所经历的过程
所进行的建设
以及架构
我坚信
自己所扮演的
每个角色
都是我今生能够扮演的。
唯一一个
也是最后一个
有一位从不干预
我这一系列的妻子。
我深感幸运
我比以往任何时候。
都更加热爱表演
分享这一段
我没想到马修麦康娜。
提了这么多
厉害的电影之后
依然在为票房担忧。
就是
你还要怎么着
同时又回到
前面我们说的那个问题。
就是所有人的担忧。
都是现实的
都是在他那个处境里面。
非常具体的
然后还有
就是他后面说到这个表演。
就是我热爱表演
这个表演和我刚才前面说的那种。
创作者的表演状态。
是两码事
绝对是两个表演
一个是
马修麦康娜
他是作为演员
真的在去
创造一个角色
是呈现一个东西
表演一个东西出来。
然后刚才我前面说的那种。
就是我在自我反思。
自己的那种表演状态。
是一种
试图去控制
试图去掌握一些
你不可控的
你掌握不到的
就像他说的
是本人问题
是选题
是电视本身
是发现不利
还是实在不同了
就这些忙忙多的
指向虚空的
虚武的问题
那是我们控制不了的。
我们也不应该太去。
对那些问题有执念。
我分享这一段
我最后来分享一个。
是在第四章叫下坡的艺术。
就是讲他红了之后。
整个人
反倒陷入一种
非常慌张的状态
再有点吵
我给大家节选几段来念。
首先是他红了之后。
他发生了什么？
有一个特别有意思的描述。
他描述说
他这个电影叫杀陆时刻。
他的首映当天
他去买他最爱吃的那个三明治。
结果发现
我和大约400人打了照面。
除了四个人之外
其余的396个人。
并没有注意到我
几个姑娘
觉得我挺帅气
还有一个男生
喜欢我的鞋子
然后说这个电影
播完了之后
他说我又当了
街上买了一份
口叫母面包夹金枪鱼。
买的东西都一样
然后说我一路上
大约和400人打了照面。
其中396个人
都盯着我看
只有四个人
没有注意到我
其中三个是婴儿
还有一个是盲人
我检查一下
我的裤子拉链
用拇指清扫鼻子
看看上面
有没有挂着鼻屎
还好一切正常
这到底是怎么回事。
原来我出名了
他说
然后说
围绕我的闪亮登场的。
炒作铺天盖地
在登上行业杂志封面时。
被誉为
下一位大热明星的。
我的脑后
竟然赫然印着
马修麦康娜
电影的大救星的
粗体大写字母
大救星
别扯了
我根本就不认为
电影还需要人来挽救。
就算事实真的如此。
我也不确定
我真的是让影片
转败为圣的救星
更不想将这个大量。
挑在身上
我只是单纯想要演戏。
在我认为
有意义的故事中
扮演感兴趣的角色。
从那天开始
世界变成了一面镜子。
陌生人会把手
搭在我的身上
用老友般的语气
跟我说话
实际上
他们已经
根本不能算是陌生人了。
与我素卫谋面的人。
竟会向我走来说
我的狗狗也得了癌症。
很抱歉
听到铁汉小姐
得病的消息
这个铁汉小姐的狗。
你是怎么知道
我养狗的事的
你怎么知道他的名字。
你怎么知道
他可能得了
癌症
人和人之间
已经无需自我介绍了吗？
每个人心中
都有一份关于
我的预设简历
坦诚的第一印象
已成为过眼云烟
时过境迁
一去不返了
我的整个事情
都变了
借用詹姆斯
麦克莫特里的歌词来说。
如今一切
上下颠倒
前后倒置
早已物是人非
然后就是他
陷入了
巨大的惶恐之中
他说
我需要一次
精神的重新校准
当时的我
头脑一片混乱
我迷失在
刚刚获得的圣明之中。
认为自己
不配得到这一切
然后他怎么办
他就找了一个寺院。
找一个修士来告解。
他说
我将自己的罪恶感。
侵吐而出
那些我曾在
脑海中
神有过的粗鄙
和银鞋之地
还有那些
偏激而直扭的思想。
我坦言说
自从成名你来
我一直想努力
做个好人
尽量不欺人
也不自欺
希望心灵
和思想
变得更加纯净
但我被欲望
所冲涉
用不化的视角
去审视自己
和他人
我感觉不到
与过去的联系
也看不清
通往未来的路
感觉徬徨无一
我觉得
我好像失去了自己。
整整三个半小时里。
我向克里斯蒂安修士。
亲素着心中的恶魔。
狠狠斥责自己
他却一句话
也没有说
完全亦不发
他只是一边耐心聆听。
一边与我一起
肩并肩传过沙漠
差不多四个小时之后。
我回到了教堂
一起坐在门口的长凳上。
现在的我
已经气不成声
忏悔也终于步入尾声。
我静静地
与克里斯蒂安修士。
坐在一起
等待着他的审判
终于
我在这让人
不安的寂静中
抬起头来
这么长时间
一直莫不作声的
克里斯蒂安修士
看着我的双眼
亲身告诉我
我也一样
有的时候
我们并不需要建议。
我们只需听到
自己并非孤身一人。
又是一盏绿灯
我就分享这一段吧？
我当时看这一段的时候。
非常感慨
我的情感大概是三重。
第一重是一个人
他真的很会表演
而且我们能从
他的过往当中看出来。
他真的是在表演方面。
天赋一丙
然后他有一招
一日红了
就是按照我自己的逻辑。
我觉得他正常的反应。
应该是说
老子终于红了
我终于被看见了
这一切是我应得的。
结果他是怎么样
我刚才读那段
他有巨大的惶恐
他说我还能拯救电影。
我根本不配
有巨大的不配得感。
然后他就开始
感觉到了罪恶
开始进行了反省
我觉得这个让我非常非常感慨。
我觉得这也是一个。
跟我们今天挺反持绝的事。
我们可能觉得说
我们今天老讲的是什么？
你得有配得感
你得知道我配得起这一切。
但是我一直觉得
配得感这个事
他也是分角度去看的。
比如说我们要觉得自己。
能配得上一些人
我们不能老去
让自己接受那些
我要和不好的境遇在一起。
我要和不好的人在一起。
我觉得可能我不值得。
更好的人
我觉得在这个时候。
我们可能要讲配得感。
但是像这种波天的声明。
这些名誉加诸在身上。
我有的时候觉得
那个不配得感
反倒是好事
我们来看
马修迈康娜的生活。
你会发现能让她
不断的在进步
不断的突破自己
其实往往就是
加诸在身上的这些惶恐。
她觉得我是吗？
我不行吧？
就是这种东西
让她一直在保持了一种饥饿。
一直保持的这种谦悲。
才让她有不停的
转变的可能
对
这是我第一个感悟。
第二个感悟
就是她和修迟的这段对话。
你看这个修迟听完之后。
没有审判她
也没有急于给她安慰。
只说了一句话说
我也这样
这就提醒我
我觉得我们有的时候。
接受朋友的这些
跟你的求助也好
跟你的亲素也好
我们有的时候
太急需安慰人了
太急需帮她
给出她一些建议
给她一些行动纲领。
但有的时候你会知道。
这个朋友可能需要的。
就是那句话说
我在听
我可能跟你也一样。
我也不知道该怎么办。
这个有的时候
就是说
她的情绪被接纳住。
和被安顿住了
所以我就觉得这段。
我特别喜欢
我就跟大家分享这么多吧？
那成
我们这个片段分享就到这吧？
然后我们最后再跟大家。
聊一个小问题吧？
就是咱们抛开这本书不谈。
就是讲马修麦康娜这个人。
我不知道你们读完之后。
有没有觉得说
她身上有些东西
是对我们当下的生活。
具有启发和建设性的意义的。
或者哪一点
对你个人挺有启发。
大老师刚才说的
创作方面
对吧有对象感
我不知道就是她
整个人生的哲学
或者她那些绿灯时刻。
有没有让你觉得
我学到了一点
可能对我有帮助的。
第一次看这个书的时候。
我会想说这个绿灯。
副标题是不是说
我一路开挂的人生。
就是随于这种
一切发生皆有利于我。
所有的选择都是最好的安排。
然后我所以人生一路绿灯。
后来我发现
她的人生肯定是拒绝了。
许多路口的转向
你才能一路绿灯
如果你一直开在一个。
要左转的车道上面。
你可能遇到红灯和黄灯的概率。
会比直行或者右转的绿灯。
多的多的多
当然
所以在整个
这本书的阅读体验里面。
我会觉得我好像更接近了。
马兴麦康奈
他作为一个人
一个真实的普通的。
一个和我们差不多的。
那个人之所以为人的那种状态。
就是他会有他的怀疑。
有他的不确定
不想要的
也有他纠结说
我要不要去做这件事情。
这种摇摆
这种摇摆不存在
我们刚才说前面那种企业家式的。
堵定说
哥们就是看中这条赛道了。
就绝对能成
不是这种东西
当然同时他也
这本书也绝对不可能给我们提供。
一个参考路线说
我如何学习马兴麦康奈。
成为一个奥斯卡影帝。
你要这么想
绝对是瞎了心了
肯定也不会有人这么去看这本书。
所以他处于一个中间状态。
就既没有强调名人的那种成功叙事。
他也把一个普通人的。
值得我们去认识的状态还原出来。
这个尺度我觉得是把握的蛮好的。
所以看到这个就会。
想说那马兴麦康奈遇到这么多问题。
跟我人生遇到的许多问题。
都是一样的
他也许没有解
就是他没有一个答案。
说怎么着这个问题就解决了。
而是说
我们都要在这条路上。
继续往下走下去
星光呢？
我觉得我这次读这本。
马兴麦康奈的专辑。
给我的一个特别大的启发。
是其实我们没有必要。
特别执着于专辑作品的。
真实性到底有多少。
或者说
如果我们的阅读目的是。
从这部作品当中
得到和我有关系的东西的时候。
那么哪怕在这样的作品当中。
有部分的情节
部分的心理状态的描写。
是被虚构的
我觉得他也依然能够。
从另一个方向去反映。
专主或者作者的
某种真实的心理状态。
换句话说就是假设。
退一半步
我们从事实挖掘的层面。
通过交叉验证发现。
这个作者其实是在说谎。
针对某一件事
那么我们再往身里面。
去挖一层
他为什么要说这个谎。
他为什么要把事实。
粉饰和包装成
书里面的那个样子。
他的目的是什么？
反映了他的哪种心理状态。
就因为我们知道
人无论因为什么而撒谎。
他的核心肯定是
他想要掩盖
或避免的这件事
对于他来讲非常重要。
重要到不稀为之撒谎的程度。
所以当我们发现
有这种事实表达上的。
不真实的时候
也许我们能够从另一个角度去。
亏欠这个人更真实的心态。
和他想要隐藏起来的那部分。
表达
或者他更在乎的东西是什么？
那么是不是
这个观察本身
就让我们也会
构建起合这部作品之间的关系。
让我们能够从中获得一些什么？
就这个新的起发
对我的思路的打开在于。
当我在面对一本
转积类的作品
或者回忆录的作品的时候。
我的心态会更平和。
我阅读的时候
就不会再像以前一样执着于说。
我一定要读到的东西是真实的。
如果我发现是虚打的。
我根本就不会读
或者说
我不会执着于
对这个作者有那种。
推谋求赐的
他一定要把他内心。
所思所想的
细微的东西表达出来的技术。
而是会把他书本上的文字。
和我所处的
世界变动的事实和复杂的人。
结合在一起去看
去感受
去判断
然后在阅读当中
我如果感受到的那些情绪。
可以是钦佩
可以是赞美
也可以是厌恶
也可以是反感
也可以是比
不赞同
都可以
那我觉得这些情绪。
伴随着我的阅读
自然而然的
这个传记当中
所记载的这个人的人生故事。
就是可以被更高级别的去理解。
更重要的是
我通过阅读他的传记。
知道他的故事之后。
我的生命体验
也好像被扩宽了
就是如果我能从中。
得到一些起敌道理。
或者能用于我自己人生的实践。
我觉得这种阅读就是有意义的。
不管我读到的这个作品里面。
是不是有某些
可能被粉饰的部分。
所以
我觉得读传记
就是少炸着他人
多关照自己
这个是我从这本书里的阅读当中。
得到的一些启发
而且
我觉得类似这种名人传记。
不管是在世的
还是那些已经不在世的。
已经被大家所公认的。
写的好的那些传世的。
传记作品
读这些人的故事
其实我觉得就像我们老说的一个比喻。
就像是从工具箱里面。
我们去找那些有用的工具。
就哪怕这个工具箱里面。
有这个人用过的
他觉得特别好用的那些什么？
锤子
斧子
刀枪剑极 斧叶勾叉。
但是对这些
也许对读书的我们来说。
都没太大用
你如果从中
只能找到一把小改缀。
然后这把小改缀
对你有一点点起敌。
有一点点帮助
对你的生活
有一点点作用的话。
那我觉得这本专辑作品。
就没白读
我觉得他就对我们而言是有意义的。
刘哥呢？
这本书对我最大的启发。
就是
我知道了什么叫认真生活。
我前面不是讲了
这个对于作者的介绍。
说他是一个认真生活的男人。
我在想说
到底什么叫认真生活。
就是我会发现
马修麦康娜真的是非常。
就是非常严肃的
对待了他生活当中的。
每一个转折点
比如说他在事业上。
他拿到每一个角色。
这里边有
他人生的第一个角色。
只有一句台词
他没有让这个东西滑过。
很多人就说
这不就没有表演吗？
我可以来
但是他那天他就
我前面讲了
他想到了他的哥哥。
他是怎么抽烟的
他那天是怎么样
包括后边有
我刚才分享那个
让他名声大造的那部作品。
他在演一个辩护律师。
他拿到这个角色的时候。
首先那个角色
并不属于他
是他自己争取来
他觉得我想演这个。
同时
当时导演已经有了台词。
他已经走过一遍了。
他觉得那个表演
可以达到及格
但是他依然觉得那个。
好像不是正常的状态。
他在想说
我拿到这个角色
导演说
如果是你
你会怎么处理
他说我会说什么？
我会做什么？
如果一名还是处女的。
年轻女孩
被三个恶棍强奸
我会做和感想
那天
他们把女孩
心中的什么杀死了。
如果受害的是我的妹妹呢？
如果是我的女儿呢？
那天正好是母亲节。
你看她
会非常深刻的去
剖析这个角色
她对待工作妹
一个机会都是认真。
什么叫认真
就是我不能用我的本能。
用我过去的经验
去随意处置一件事。
即便我有这么丰富的。
表演经验
我还是在认真思考。
我觉得这是一个认真。
另外是
当他生活当中遇到了。
很多卡点
比如说
父母去世
或者他面对婚姻
和即便有那么爱的女人。
他会发现
我在结婚的那天
我为什么？
没有选择第一时间。
和他结婚
我在畏惧什么？
我在恐惧什么？
还有就是我前面分享。
他的演艺事业当中。
圣明而来的时候
他也没有安然的
就享受这些圣明
他发现了自己
内心的那些
空虚和惶恐
他去找一个人去告解。
他在处理
积极地处理
和应对这些问题
我觉得这就叫认真生活。
你不能让你生活中。
遭遇的东西
就那么着
划过去了
我本能地承接住了。
我就顺应了
他把每一个
来到他面前的东西。
他都经过了思考
然后进行了分类整理。
有些东西
他发现处理不了
那我让他在那儿
当一会儿
有些东西
我觉得这对我来说。
是一个必须的
处理和面对的东西。
那我就花时间
花精力去把它解决掉。
我觉得这就是
认真生活
那认真生活的结果是什么？
就是你会看到一个人。
他在真的是在不断地成长。
他在不断地累积
包括他为什么能写回忆录。
他写了那么多日记。
有的时候这些日记。
写在纸上的这些碎片。
我们都觉得是蓄到。
对吧？
就觉得你没有必要。
为什么呢？
你看就是这些
他把很多
我们觉得没有必要。
你凑不凑合
混过去就得了的事。
他没有混
他都是在
用尽一切的办法
去思考
去面对
去应对
让他成为了今天的。
马修麦康娜
我觉得这个
特别值得我们去学习。
我们有的时候
特别容易说
我今天太累了
要不然算了吧？
就互动互动得了
或者说
哎呀这东西
别人都那么弄的
我也这么弄吧？
大家都那样
我为什么不能那样的。
比我厉害的人都那样。
我有什么本事
能让他变得不一样的。
算了吧？
我觉得人生真的就是。
你不能轻易的就说算了。
不经意的一个算了。
再加一个算了
就让我们错过了
很多机会
没错
这就是我看完这本书。
对我影响非常大的。
我觉得从今天起
即便是顺进来的时候。
我们应该
也有那些说
我停下来想一想
这是我应该得到的吗？
我这一切
是该给我的吗？
我觉得就是多思考。
这些问题
其实挺好的
关于这本书
和今天的节目
我们就到这
大家可以在留言区。
给我们说说
如果你读过这本书。
可以跟我们说说
你的阅读感受
如果你特别喜欢
马修麦康娜
也可以欢迎给我们推荐一些。
你觉得他特别好的作品。
可以给我们分享分享。
不让你的人生当中。
有没有遇到一些
黄灯和红灯时刻
你是怎么通过的
怎么让它变成绿灯的。
也跟我们分享
我们会从评论区
选出五位听友
送出这本
马修麦康娜的绿灯。
这只书这一本
好
那希望你度过
接下来这个
一路绿灯
那就到这
我们下周再见
拜拜